the Gandhi is the director of the MK
Gandhi Institute for non-violence in
Memphis Tennessee and is the grandson of
MK Gandhi who led India the independence
through his nonviolent social change the
did you know well your grandfather very
well yes I was very lucky I had the
opportunity of living with him when I
was 12 years old in 1946 and I have some
very vivid memories of that time and I
know now in retrospect I am always very
puzzled how he could manage to you know
divide his attention to so many
different things at different levels for
instance with me he was absolutely
grandfather like any other grandfather
would play games with me and really
would tease each other and give me
lessons and look at my lessons and all
those things and yet the next moment he
would switch over and go to negotiations
with independence of India with the
British leaders and other leaders there
and yeah you know when I think back at
all those little things that happened
during that period irrilium feel very
happy that I was given that opportunity
because I think in many ways that one
year more than a year that I had with
him help me understand his philosophy
and more my life and thinking as an
adult and there are you know he had this
knack of explaining his philosophy using
minor everyday occurrences I can share a
few of them with you and one of them
related to a little pencil and now
you'll wonder what a little pencil has
to do with the philosophy of
non-violence but I was given a pencil in
a notebook to do my lessons with and one
day like most children I threw away the
pencil and I thought it was too small we
went to grandfather and asked him for a
new pencil and he
he started questioning where is the
pencil you had in the morning why do you
need a new pencil where did you throw it
away and all sorts of things and I
couldn't convince him that that was too
small
ultimately told me to go out and look
for the pencil and so I used the excuse
I said it's getting back outside it's
late in the evening this is he has a
flashlight and he made me go out and
look for that pencil for nearly two
hours and bring it to him and then he
made me sit next to him and he said now
I'm going to explain why I did this and
said I want you to learn two lessons
from this one is that even in the making
of a little pencil not a lot of natural
resources of the world are used and if
all of us millions of us go around
wasting pencils like this imagine how
many how much of natural resources be
erasing and we have no right to do this
now it amazes me that he was thinking
about environment and ecology in 1945-46
when that wasn't even an issue I don't
think even anybody knew the word
environment and ecology but that was one
lesson that he wanted me to learn he
says however small or however
insignificant it may seem to you never
get into the habit of wasting things
destroying things use it to the ultimate
the other lesson was that there were
millions of children around the world
who lived in such abject poverty that
they didn't have even these little
things to use so we ought to be doubly
careful about all the things that we get
and we are privileged to have so that if
we don't waste we would be able to share
with many more people what kinds of
things that your grandfather like to do
for fun I like the games you would play
what type things
can laugh for instance oh you would
laugh at many things he had this great
sense of humor and I remember when we
used to go out for walks in the morning
and evening and onion he always had the
habit of keeping two people close to him
and he would lean on their shoulders
keep his arms on their shoulders and
walked it and very often just while
walking you know it suddenly lifts up
his legs and angles okay if you're not
not aware of this and you're taken by
surprise you could collapse on it
whenever he would play such games
sometimes he had a walking stick along
with him and I would be holding the
stick in front and playing horse and you
would be sort of running after me
writing you know all very commonplace
games and but he had a great sense of
humor I know when we used to sit and
spin very often we used to sit and spin
together you know we had machine opening
cotton which was part of him a lot of
his life and independent from Britain
right and he wanted the people to
produce their own lot and use it so he
used to do that and and very often when
he was spinning I would find myself free
and I would join him and then we would
have a competition to see who spun the
thinnest Ian and who spun the most you
on in one hour and all those things in
did he talked majority tell you about
some of the things were happening in his
life at the big level national and
international level sometimes he would
talk about it not directly alone with me
but when we sat in a group or something
and he would express
some of his feelings about it but I
guess I was too small at that time 12
years old for him to confide in me of
nothing in terms of the good okay how
did you become aware that this was your
grandfather's philosophy that
non-violence was the key to social
change well during that year I saw how
he used the philosophy and how he taught
people and he would teach me also using
everyday instances and but it was never
like a lesson
it was never you know when you sit down
and he lectures to you or anything like
that it was just in the course of the
day when things were happening he would
use at any particular instance and then
give you a little story on math and and
tell you why that is important in his
philosophy you know so that's how I got
some of the basic training but I was
fortunate that my parents my father was
his second son and my mother they had
devoted their lives to his work in South
Africa and so they were conducting the
anti-apartheid movement in South Africa
non-violent manner so I got much of the
later training through them and then of
course I used it myself in several
situations and I found it was very
practical so I would say that it was a
gradual process that went on over the
years you know and I just began to learn
and appreciate more and more of his
philosophy did his death have a big
impact on your life did it change it
much yeah it was very shocking and when
when it came so suddenly you know and I
couldn't imagine anybody wanting to kill
a person like him I mean you know like
it was unthinkable and when that news
came to me I just couldn't believe it
none of us could go for the funeral and
father was very disturbed by that but we
used to bring out a weekly newspaper
called the opinion it was paper that was
started by grandfather in 1903 he had
experiences earlier yeah so her father
decided to bring out a special issue on
commemorating grandfather and we all got
involved in in that and since this was a
self operated hand operated printing
press where we had to pick up the
alphabets and set them ABCD and make the
words there I got my grounding in in
this printing press at a very early age
and I started helping in various ways so
by 14 I was already quite into it and
able to help my parents bring up and
bring out this weekly paper and so you
ended up then staying in South Africa
for the next year's and my father died
in 1956 and I went to India after his
death to immerse his ashes in the rivers
in India and there I met my wife and we
decided to get married the South African
government said that I can come back
alone but I can't bring my wife with me
oh my goodness yeah there are two main
reasons for this one of it was that they
were always very keen on getting rid of
the Gandhi family from South Africa
because the that exam were taught in
their flesh and they felt that this was
a good opportunity because father had
just died and I was the only male member
and they thought that if they didn't
allow me to come back then my mother and
my two sisters would follow me to India
and and they would be rid of the family
but I guess they didn't count on the
resilience of the Gandhi women they
decided to stay on and continue with the
work in in South Africa at that time in
South Africa were the people from India
treated differently from the blacks in
South Africa they were put into a
separate category were they not yeah
they they really perfected this divide
and rule policy in South Africa and so
the Indians the black Africans and the
coloreds the mulatos who weren't
classified as coloreds everybody was
treated separately everybody had
different set of laws but everybody was
generally treated as a non-white the
South African system was classified into
four categories the first were the
whites and the whites were of two types
to the British descendants and the
Afrikaner descendants the Afrikaner were
slightly more in number and for many
years they had been subjugated by the
British so there wasn't very good
relationship between them either well
the British had divided the men aboard
we are right they were rid of Dutch
descent sentence they understand mmm but
right up to 1948 the British controlled
South Africa in 1948 was the first time
the Nationalist Party made up of Dutch
people came into power so they were the
first group then came the coloreds
the coloreds were the mulattos the
mixture of blacks and whites or the
Malays in Cape Town they had imported a
lot of people from Malay
Lygia and so there was a mixture of them
with the white and mix of many other
races with right so they were all
classified as coloreds so they came the
second in the second group the third
group were the Indians and the fourth
group or the local African tribes now
where did the Asian people the Chinese
the Japanese said the Japanese here are
very White's terror to the other a
Asians come in they they are all in the
same group as the Indians there were not
too many of the other Asians the
Japanese were in a higher category than
the Chinese or the Koreans they that was
for trade purposes they had a lot of
trade with Japan so they couldn't
discriminate against them so they
treated them as honorary White's that
was the classification given to them
honorary White's you remember any
particular experiences there that were
yes I was in fact like my grandfather I
suffered a lot of discrimination and
beatings physical beatings or because of
color in South Africa you experience
hate and discrimination and oppression
almost at every step when you're walking
down the streets and anybody could
insult you you know I remember one
instance I was sitting in the car
waiting for my father to return parked
on the side there and it was very close
to the bar and a white walked out from
the swaggering he was drunk and it was
clearly a hobo he didn't have anything
to do and he comes around to me and he
says hey give me a book that's a
shilling so I said I'm sorry if I
started insulting me
and there's a policeman standing nearby
and I told the policeman as I looked in
this fellow's harrassing me heaven I
don't like it
the policeman turned around on me and he
says if you don't like it get out of
here what are you doing sitting here for
he doesn't tell that man anything maybe
he tells me to get out from you know
that sort of things all the time you
just have to bear with it or keep
fighting at all them and what about
organized struggle were you involved in
a movement for social was my father was
involved in movement and as I said we
family members were always involved with
our parents in various aspects of the
movement we did defy of course I was
still young so I wasn't taken to prison
but my father was taken to prison very
often and I think he spent about in all
16 to 17 years of his life in prison
like Nelson Mandela the same surest in
the leaders of the movement except that
it wasn't at one stretch it was at
different times and what types of things
would he be accused of doing what did he
do he just defied apartheid wherever he
saw it plus his newspaper I guess his
newspaper person writing in the
newspaper were there multiracial
multicultural organizations which were
forming to try to provide this front
against the apartheid yeah not until the
6th year and not 60 heading in 50 52
around 52 is the first time when the
the African National Congress the Indian
National Congress and the colored
People's Congress three of them came
together and held a common conference
and they said let's make common cause
and fight together instead of separately
and that was the first time they decided
then but it didn't last very long
because they decided it was going to be
a non-violent struggle in and then they
couldn't find a common law that affected
all three of them together in our part
ID law and so that was a big problem and
eventually when they did find one one or
two of them and they went and defied
those laws the government played a
radically clever trick on them they gave
each group a different jail sentence in
the African group suffered the most for
breaking the same law in the African
were sentenced to one years hard labor
the Indian was sentenced to one month
hard labor and the colored person was
sentenced to one week or something like
that you know it was ridiculous
listening so very quickly they broke up
that coalition but loosely they
continued to function together in in a
very sort of loose fashion how would you
compare the caste system in India with
apartheid in South Africa well it's the
same thing is it like in South Africa
the whites with the superior it was
always a vertical division of people in
the whites were at the top and in India
the Brahmins were at the top there and
then
like kshatriyas and the privations at
the sudras these were the four
classifications and so the whites
they're the coloreds the Indians and the
blacks and each one of them
discriminating and oppressing the those
below them so that's exactly what
happened in in yells of the caste system
the three upper caste people would
always oppress the low caste and the you
know it was so I've had many many
parallels in the situation
I also found many parallels and the way
the whole system was created to oppress
people and and how that was perpetuated
through all these years of course in
India it's been there for more than
2,000 years earlier even in India before
the birth of Christ
there was this caste system but there
was mobility up and down there was no
rigid you know blockages and so a person
at the very bottom of the ladder if he
or she had the opportunity they could
move upwards the person from the top
could come down and there was that
freedom to move up and learn was that
mainly by economic yeah caste system is
based on professions mainly based on
profession so fixed from family to for
generation to generation
that's what happened around the birth of
Christ 2,000 years ago and we had who
was described as a Hindu lawmaker Manu
whether he was a king or he was just as
somebody you
who made the laws I don't know it's not
very clear that but Manu laid down the
laws around the time of birth of Christ
when he made caste hereditary and he
said henceforth you know your cash will
be determined by birth and the that's
where all the discrimination and
oppression came in it freezes the
socio-economic clear all right so you
couldn't do anything to get out of it
there's absolutely nothing you could do
to get out of it and that's where the
whole thing all the unpleasantness came
in that's still that way it's still that
way unfortunately I think grandfather
expected the government to abolish the
system at all together and and you know
help people to get over that thing but
they what they ended up doing is they
just made it illegal to discriminate
against somebody on the basis of caste
or religion or race of or gender the low
caste people who were discriminated
against they had to go and prove to the
the police and the courts of law that
they have been oppressed or
discriminated and these people didn't
have the means they didn't have the
education they didn't have the finances
to do these things and also very often
the person who oppressed them or
discriminated against them was their
employer so they couldn't very well go
and Institute legal proceedings against
somebody who's providing them bread and
butter
you can also probably have to go up
before a judge who was at a higher caste
yeah right yeah all of these things put
together they never did institute any
cases and so you go to India today and
government will give you statistics to
show that there are no cases of
discrimination in India Africa there
were that's only half the truth who has
nobody has instituted the proceedings
how can there be any statistics of cases
then at all did
Nehru try to bust the caste system were
there any progressive social changes
under his rule he was one of the
lieutenant's of your grandfather who was
taken to be one of the more progressive
of the Indian socialist national and
Indian nationalists for independence and
was quite a distinguished person ruled
India for a long time did he not make an
effort to follow your grandfather's
teaching in terms of eliminating the
caste system or was he a disappointment
well I personally was very disappointed
with him I thought that he would do much
more in this field to break the caste
system there but obviously he didn't do
it and I think the only reason I can
find it is that at the time of
Independence
more than 99.9 percent of the government
and the bureaucracy was made up of the
two upper caste people the Brahmins and
exoti as niro himself was a Brahmin and
so they didn't want to threaten their
own existence and and so the only thing
that I ended up doing is like I said and
putting it in the Constitution that they
will have equal rights and they would
not be discriminated just as we did with
the blacks here in the United States
they were granted civil rights but that
was all not legally you can do all these
things but then to implement that in in
real life it's very difficult we see
that in the United States also and we
see it in India that we are not able to
translate the law in
in everyday life there so the actual
integration of the people hasn't taken
place now Indira Gandhi for many years
was also the Prime Minister of the ruler
president of India what's the
relationship between your family and
Indira Gandhi's family and what is your
sense of her to the extent that she did
or did not follow the legacy of your
grandfather well first of all let me say
that she wasn't related to us in any way
at all in fact she was very astute in
misleading people not only in India but
outside about this relationship and let
me explain this the Gandhi that she
married is was a descendant from Iran
known as a Parsi and they used to spell
their name they did have the family name
Gandhi but they used to spell it very
differently it was G H a and D H hy and
she changed it to the Hindu spelling of
the name to confuse people and see guys
she got that you know Sid she was able
to do that and so a lot of people
everywhere in the world today think that
she was directly related to the Gandhi
so to that extent he used Gandhi's name
there but unfortunately she didn't do
anything concrete or progressive to
implement his philosophy I don't think
she really believed in anything very
much she's just a politician he was a
politician she was out for power and she
was one of those people who believed
that Gandhi
wasn't realistic his ideas of cottage
industry and all that were outdated and
they were not the answer to India but
that was because they approached his
philosophy dogmatically and and I think
that that was a great injustice to
Gandhi because he didn't expect anybody
to follow him dogmatically he wanted
people to evolve from his philosophy and
build up on that and and I think that
although he did talk so much about
cottage industries and things like that
but that he was talking in terms of the
30s 20s and 30s India and if he was
living today I am sure he would have
accepted many other things in his
philosophy now when did you leave South
Africa to return to India for a year and
you weren't allowed to go back to South
Africa then and so what were some of
your experiences then in India was this
in the 1950s yeah and they said I left
South Africa in 56 after my father's
death and remarried in 58 early 58 and
they wouldn't allow me to come back with
my wife so I decided to stay on in India
and I had to get a job as a journalist
in Times of India and then in early 60
baath my wife and I had decided that
along with our normal work and lively
when we ought to be doing some Social
Work also to help people so we began to
get involved in things and my wife got
involved with the status of battered
women in India and
abandoned children both of these
problems are very acute in India we have
lots of battered women and many
abandoned children and then from that we
got involved in the caste the low caste
Untouchables and that's when we really
started implementing some of our
grandfather's philosophies of
non-violence in in helping these people
first of all it was an experiment we we
ourselves were not very sure that this
would work or not we had heard it in
theory but we had never seen it in
practice so we decided to put it in
practice we adopted one village of more
than 260 untouchable families about 200
miles south of Bombay and we had to
spend a lot of time trying to get
accepted by them they had been exploited
so much that they began became
suspicious of everybody they didn't want
anybody to come and exploit them further
so for several months we had to go every
day and speak to them and and you know
make our case to them and ultimately
they did accept us and once they did
then we started taking them into
confidence as grandfather suggested we
started working our programs what what
were the priorities that they needed and
how could we help them in this and it
was very clear that economic stability
was one of the prime importance there so
we had to find ways of giving them
economic stability well in 1960 these
people were in such dire poverty that
they are never eating a square meal in
their lives they just survived on scraps
of food that they got from the garbage
they never tasted milk in their lives
they had no clothes to wear very often
we would go to
their little hearts to visit them and
the women would talk from inside and not
open the doors to us and then then we
found it because they didn't have any
clothes they couldn't come out and speak
to us that was the level of poverty that
we found but we took advantage of some
of the government programs at that time
the government was very keen on
developing the dairy industry because it
was big demand for milk in the cities so
they were giving liberal loans to people
to buy animals and produce milk and sell
that milk to the mother dairy and all
that so we asked these people to go and
apply for those loans but when they did
so the government refused saying that
you don't have any collateral and so we
had to fancy her CEO duties for them get
them the loans and they each got of an
animal per family and that was the first
time that they tasted milk and that
vision is still there in my mind you
know and they first got the milk from
the animals and and they took the first
sip there and I mean it was so in a
sense it was you know pathetic that
people a common thing like milk was
never given to some people but it was a
very moving experience and then they
began to sell that milk to the
government and that became an income for
them and from that we help them develop
an agricultural cooperative and through
these cooperatives in about eight or
nine years we transform the economic
base of that village totally they began
to get steady income and sizeable income
every month
and they began to eat well and you know
wear clothes and send their children to
schools and all those things and and you
could see that transformation in them
and then we induce them to save some
money for various programs of their own
like medical facilities and scholarships
and things like that and then there was
another big problem there in that in
that whole area because of poverty there
the agencies to come from the cities and
by young girls to take them away into
prostitution and they would buy these
girls for $12 and $15 and they were gone
you know at the age of 1012 there and
they went and they never came back again
because they told the parents that they
were taking them to the city and going
to give them jobs and all that in
somebody's homes but in actual fact they
were taken to prostitution so we wanted
to put an end to that and we told these
people like now you must ensure that
nobody reaches that stage of desperation
that they have to sell their daughters
into prostitution and you set aside some
money for that and they didn't and they
also created a volunteer group of young
men who would scour around the villages
in that area and see that nobody ever
sold their daughters and whenever
anybody was in a desperate need of money
or something they would help them
through this fun so since 1973 and they
stopped the sale of pregnant girls in
about nearly 200 villages in the name of
her
remar and and not only that but then you
know we had inspired them all along that
they should not become selfish that once
they have a 10 deck anomic stability
they should be willing to help other
people so they are now doing that they
are very well-off economically now and
in all these years their young people
have gotten education and come back and
running their businesses very well but
they are also you know in helping other
young people in the neighboring villages
you know set up economic programs there
and so this economic program of theirs
and now expanded to about 300 villages
and covers about a half a million
population its remarked and this is
independent of the government of India
noria are totally independent people
organizing themselves well this was the
beauty of Gandhi's philosophy of
non-violence it was a more positive
philosophy and not just a protest
philosophy it wasn't protest movement
alone but if you got involved in
something you didn't like something do
positively to change that you know in
creating or create an alternative I so
that's that's where we really found the
the strength of this philosophy when we
saw the results in this village and how
in a very short time just seven of us
using giving our part-time help because
all seven of us had to work for our
livelihood the only thing we did was to
sacrifice our vacation time in the
little free time
and go there and help them and advise
them and do things for them apart from
that we didn't really do anything very
much but even that little help could
transform the lives of so many people
what is the legacy of your grandfather
today in India and around the world well
I would say in many ways in many senses
I think he's more respected outside
India than he is inside him here inside
India very few people now we have the
time to care for him except to exploit
his name whenever it's necessary for
whatever means and it's very really sad
the way they do it their little
incidents in which I'm involved easily
I started this Institute in memory of
grandfather and my parents in Memphis
Tennessee and I wrote a letter to the
prime minister of India the present
Prime Minister asking him to donate
through the Government of India
all the books written by a known Gandhi
the videotapes and the films and audio
tapes and all the things that they have
there please make a copy of it and give
it to me so that I can keep it in this
Institute and it will help in teaching
young people the philosophy of
non-violence and I got a letter saying
that he was sending it over to the
relevant ministries and I will hear from
them shortly well I did hear from them a
year later and they said we have passed
all your requests you can take all these
things but we don't have the money to
mail it to you to ship it to you so you
will have to make arrangements to ship
it you will have to make arrangements
for somebody to copy all the films and
the photographs and all that pay for the
copies and so I said okay that's fine
find some donor in the US who can do it
and then two months later I read in the
newspapers the government of india
started a narrow center in london and
they sent spent three million dollars
there to renovate the building and to
you know make spruce it up and there's
now shipping all the furniture required
for that center from india at the
expense of the government your
grandfather's philosophy represents a
threat to the present day rulers of
India as well as other oppressive
governments all over the world and I
just do not want to support social
movements and social activism that
threatens the status quo whereas Nehru
is a Western Iser a moderate politician
as he turns out to be who's very Pro
British in certain ways oh yeah as
evidenced by the fact that in London
they're having this Center so it's not
terribly surprising let's conclude the
discussion we're talking about how you
came to the United States you were
involved in the struggles in India that
you told us in detail about to help the
villagers and particularly the
untouchable class and fight the caste
system what led you to leave India and
to come to the United States well I had
all these experiences in India and in
South Africa and especially in India
where I used Graham grandfather's
philosophy very effectively in bringing
about these social and economic changes
there and I thought that that was
something that I needed to share with
other people and there was an American
friend was visiting India this was in 82
83 and I just got talking to him about
this work and he came and saw the work
that we were doing and
I was very impressed by and while we
were talking the idea came into my mind
why not write a book comparing these
attitudes in South Africa India and the
United States one place you have the
Glacial discrimination in another place
to catch discrimination and in the third
place the color discrimination compare
this and find nonviolent solutions to it
and write a book on heaven he was very
taken up by the idea and he said if
you'd like to come to the US and do that
I could make it possible for you so he
arranged for a fellowship for one year
to come get and do it and that's how I
came here in 87 and while working on
that project in Mississippi the media
heard about me and and I started getting
invited by universities to speak and all
that and so after the fellowship ended
we just extended our stay with this
money that I was earning through
speaking engagements and at the same
time working on the e-book and one thing
led to another and then in 88 my mother
died and that's when I went to South
Africa to be by her side and it was the
first time I saw the Gandhi Institute in
South Africa totally destroyed and
demolished it was a double tragedy for
me it was on one hand I lost my mother
and I see their life's worked with all
the Nashes you know somebody burned it
down yeah it was the government and the
cutter together
you know conspired to demolish it so I
was thinking of starting an Institute
for the Study of non-violence initially
the idea was to do it in South Africa
sort of replacement of this Institute
that was destroyed and just to you know
inform young people of alternative ways
of dealing with conflicts there but
South Africa wasn't ready for it they
didn't accept the idea I and a lot of
political hassles is in 88 so I gave up
the idea and lots of my friends here in
the academic world they said if you
can't do it in South Africa why don't
you do it here it's needed anywhere in
the world so I looked around here and
the Christian Brothers University in
Memphis a very small University heard
about it so they offered us some
hospitality and said that they didn't
have the money but they could we could
use the facilities and I thought that
was good enough so I sold my
grandfather's letters that I inherited
from my mother the original letters a
packet of about 67 letters they were all
right from 1892 to 1948 and we were
getting old and brittle and
you know deteriorating very quickly and
I thought that I wouldn't be able to
preserve them so if I could raise some
money from that why not do that and I
did that last year I optioned them in
London but that auction caused a little
controversy in India the Government of
India accused me of commercializing God
his name and all that so the price of
the letters fell and when I got fifty
six thousand dollars and that was
invested in this Institute which is what
we are working with now but now a lot of
people locally have heard about it that
they are very sympathetic and they give
us donations so we have been working for
the last one year in that Institute and
I think we'll be able to do quite a lot
of work there one of the things that we
want to take up immediately is 1994 is
the grandfather 125th birth anniversary
and I wanted to use that as a peg to
declare 1994 as a year of non-violence
to commemorate all the people all over
the world who sacrificed for the
nonviolent change you know and and
simultaneously have programs to you know
inform people and they educate people in
nonviolent conflict resolution it's
ironic that his home country has turned
his back on him but the rest of the
world has really embraced him and his
philosophy and that's what I was saying
that the rest of the world is it
respects him and how is this have you
seen this happening in various different
parts of the world the impact well I
think it's been tremendous and and
wherever I've been outside India the
interest in Gandhi and the in his
philosophy and all that has been
tremendous and we can see it in everyday
life I mean the influences in Eastern
Europe and all over the place changes
have been taking place in a non-violent
manner and much of that has been his
influence one way or the other
and do you envisage participated in some
nonviolent social change and activism
projects in the United States as you all
know or in Luther King in the civil
rights movement was deeply influenced by
your grandfather's teaching disease and
contemporary projects that this might be
applied in the United States one of the
things that I want to do very soon is to
hold a conference of youth here we see
the youths having many problems that is
violence among the youth and and a lot
of disaffection among the youths and
drugs and all that now all of these
things tell me that there is a lot of
frustration among the youth but we have
never consulted the youth about it it's
always the experts the adults who
analyze the problems of the youth and
provide the solutions and those
solutions are not accepted by the youth
so you know things just get worse and
worse what I want to do is to reverse
the process they have this conference of
the youth where the youths are going to
talk they are going to help find try to
find some solutions we can help them in
whatever way they want to but they must
take the initiative and they must come
up with the solutions there and we
adults must sit and listen to them I
think that's what we need to do in many
things in fact this is what I've been
trying to
explained to many of the civil rights
leaders and also people in Memphis that
we now have to change our focus from
protesting to doing something positive
you're in for long we have been
protesting and protesting and protesting
let's get down to doing something
positive ourselves and not wait for the
government to do things